З  Великобританії небажані російські дипломати
виїхали ще тиждень тому - 20 березня.
Тепер - черга збиратися їхнім колегами з російських
посольств у понад двадцяти інших країнах - від США
та Канади до Австралії та України.
Усього майже сто п"ятдесят росіян оголошено
шпигунами та персонами нон ґрата як відповідь на
отруєння на території Британії екс-полковника ГРУ
Сергія Скрипаля та його доньки.
В Києві росіянам дали 48 годин на збори, в інших країнах - тиждень.
Україна після Сполучених Штатів вислала чи не
найбільше співробітників російської дипмісії - 13.
Чим відповість Росія?
Росія має в своєму розпорядженні багато варіантів,
що помститися - у сфері дипломатії,
або економіки, або навіть армії.
І саме це має непокоїти владу України.
Росія вже пригрозила Україні наслідками за
видворення своїх дипломатів.
Якщо Кремль у відповідь зробить теж ж саме
зі співробітниками українського посольства та чотирьох консульств,
Києву буде значно складніше допомагати великій
кількості політичних в'язнів та інших затриманих
українців, які перебувають у російських в'язницях та СІЗО.
Ускладняться також переговори в мінському
форматі щодо обміну військовополоненими.
Чи варто очікувати також посилення напруги на Донбасі?
Подальшу ескалацію не можна виключати, та я не
очікую різкого погіршення,
оскільки ситуація і так досить напружена.
Звичайно, Росія може використати ситуацію
в Україні як своєрідну відповідь Заходу
на видворення дипломатів.
Проте загалом відносини між Києвом і Москвою
занадто погані, щоб на них ще міг вплинути нинішній
конфлікт між Росією і Британієї, між Росією і Заходом.
На думку політолога, не варто боятися й повного
згортання зустрічей у мінському та нормандському форматі,
бо вони все одно вже довгий час не приносили результатів.
Крім того, Росія й раніше не виконувала Мінських угод,
так само не діяло припинення вогню
на лінії розмежування на Донбасі.
Натомість нинішня криза між Заходом та Росією
потенційно може принести Україні більше розуміння
та підтримки з боку Європи та США щодо російської
агресії на Донбасі та анексії Криму, вважає експерт.